Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
En janvier 2015,
pour mon anniversaire,
je reçois un cadeau :
une boîte en carton sur laquelle
il y a marqué en gros « Push ».
Je regarde la photo sur la boîte,
je comprends que c’est un instrument
souvent utilisé par les DJs
pour faire de la musique électronique.
Sauf que moi, j’ai fait le conservatoire
et à ce moment-là de ma vie,
je pratique la musique
de manière plus conventionnelle
avec un clavier, ma voix, un piano
et bien sûr, sur scène,
je joue avec d’autres musiciens.
Donc, vraiment, cette machine,
je n’en ai pas besoin.
Même si la photo m’intrigue et me fascine,
j’avoue qu’en fait, elle me fait peur,
elle m’impressionne.
Ça me semble tellement complexe
et extra-terrestre
de faire de la musique avec ce truc.
C’est à l’opposé
de tout ce que je connais,
de ma pratique de la musique
depuis toujours :
un clavier
et des touches noires et blanches.
Alors évidemment, je me dis :
« Ce n’est pas pour moi »
et naturellement, je n’ouvre pas la boîte.
Je la laisse dans un coin
de mon appartement,
je la regarde de temps en temps
et je me dis :
« Un jour peut-être,
je serais prête à la dompter. »
Et comme par hasard,
un an plus tard, jour pour jour,
le musicien avec qui je dois faire
un concert m’appelle pour l’annuler.
Et là, je me rends compte que je ne suis
pas capable de jouer ma propre musique
seule en scène.
Et ça, ce n’est pas logique
parce que dans mon home studio,
c’est moi qui fais tout.
Je crée ma musique, je l’enregistre,
je la compose.
Mais pour la jouer sur scène,
j’ai besoin d’autres musiciens.
Et là, il me plante.
Alors qu’est-ce que je vais faire ?
Et mes yeux se posent
sur la boîte en carton,
le fameux « Push ».
Mais oui ! C’est peut-être cette
machine qui va me permettre de jouer
ma propre musique seule en scène.
Enfin… peut-être.
Donc première étape,
j’appelle la salle de concert,
et j’essaie de repousser
la date de quatre mois.
Par chance, ils disent oui.
Donc ça veut dire que j’ai quatre mois
pour apprendre à me servir de la machine
et monter un set de 45 minutes.
Donc, j'ouvre la boîte.
Et me voilà devant ce « Push ».
Je ne suis pas du genre
à lire les notices,
donc je me lance de manière intuitive.
(Aucun son ne sort de la machine)
Et très vite, je comprends
que la machine est vide.
C’est à moi d’y mettre des sons,
c’est à moi de lui donner vie
et de commencer la conversation.
Alors, je m’inspire
du monde qui m’entoure,
j’enregistre, je cherche des sons autour
de moi et je les intègre dans la machine.
(La machine joue
différents sons du quotidien)
(Porte qui se ferme)
(Bruits de la rue)
(Orgue)
(Bouton d’un lave-linge)
(Claquement de porte,
bille tapant contre une vitre)
(Vibration d’un bol tibétain)
(Notes de Kalimba)
(Son d’un feutre sur du carton)
(Notes de synthétiseur)
(Miaulement)
(Miaulements répétés)
Ça, c’est mon chat Puma.
En fait, pour moi, c’est la découverte
d’un nouveau langage.
J’essaie de communiquer
avec quelque chose d’étranger.
Et à ce moment-là, je pense à Spielberg,
« Rencontres du troisième type ».
Lui aussi essayait de communiquer avec
des extra-terrestres sur un clavier géant.
(Thème du film : Sol La Fa Fa Do)
Vous vous souvenez ?
Et ce qui est intéressant,
c’est que déjà à l’époque,
les notes étaient associées
à des couleurs.
Et pour moi, c'est une nouvelle manière
de penser et jouer la musique.
Je passe des touches noires et blanches
aux couleurs de l’arc-en-ciel.
Alors ça me donne envie d’organiser
les sons par groupes de couleurs.
Ici, les rouges, les éléments
plus boisés, plus percussifs…
(Sons de percussions)
Les bleus, les éléments
plus aériens, aquatiques.
(Sons aquatiques)
Les verts, les éléments organiques.
(Voix de femmes)
Les oranges, les éléments plus solaires.
(Sons graves)
(Mélange des sons)
(Cacophonie)
Bon, j’avoue, ce n’est pas très
harmonieux encore, je cherche.
Mais je pense qu’avec ces éléments,
je peux essayer de jouer quelque chose.
Peut-être un morceau qui existe déjà ?
Et là, une cloche sonne
à l’intérieur de moi.
(Musique de « Ring My Bell »)
(Chante) I’m glad you’re home
Now did you really miss me?
I guess you did by the look in your eye
Well lay back and relax
While I put away the dishes
Then you and me can rock a bell
You can ring my bell, ring my bell
Ding-dong-ding Ah
Ring my bell, ring it ring it ring it
You can ring my bell
Anytime anyway
(Applaudissements)
Ça, c’est le premier morceau
que je joue au « Push ».
Je trouve que ça ne sonne pas trop mal,
je le mets sur Internet, sait-on jamais.
Et là, je suis très étonnée,
j’ai de super retours.
Ça fait à peine trois semaines
que j’utilise l’instrument,
j’ai déjà des commentaires
du monde entier.
Même « The Voice » m’appelle.
Alors ça m’encourage,
ça me donne confiance.
J’ai envie de continuer
parce que, peut-être,
je vais pouvoir jouer seule en scène.
Et la date du fameux concert arrive.
Alors, j’ai peur,
je ne sais pas si je suis prête,
mais j’y vais.
Et dès les premières notes,
quelque chose se passe.
Une intimité avec le public s'installe
comme jamais auparavant.
Parce que je suis chez moi,
c’est mon laboratoire
que j’amène sur scène,
celui dans lequel je travaille
tous les jours.
Et à travers cette machine,
une connexion se crée avec le public.
Pour la première fois de ma vie, alors
que je suis en train de jouer sur scène,
je me sens à ma place.
Je sais comment, pour qui
et pourquoi je fais de la musique.
Je suis une femme, seule en scène,
avec mes machines,
autonome, indépendante,
et je peux tout faire.
Girl power !
Et ce que j’ai envie de faire par-dessus
tout, c’est raconter des histoires,
comme dans « Pierre et le Loup »,
où chaque personnage
est représenté par un instrument.
Je fais la même chose avec mes chansons,
je les pense sous la forme d’un scénario.
Si, par exemple, je veux parler de nature,
le personnage du Vent va se jouer ici.
(Son allant crescendo)
La vie, un battement de cœur.
(Son de battements de cœur)
La sève qui monte dans les arbres.
(Musique rapide)
Le soleil qui se lève.
(Son majestueux)
(Battements de cœur)
(Musique : « A Big Part of a Big Sun »)
(Chante) Put your soul into
the smallest things you do everyday
When your heart’s in many pieces
Ask if it is just a dream
Put this pain into your voice and
Let the music dry your tears
You’re not sleeping in the matrix
You’re a big part of a big big sun
Et là,
je réalise que la connexion
que j’ai avec cet instrument
n’est pas uniquement technique,
elle est aussi émotionnelle.
Je mets ma voix et mes émotions
dans la machine et elle me les renvoie.
Une relation peu à peu s'installe.
Et comme dans toute relation, parfois,
il y a des problèmes, des accidents.
Quand c’est de l’informatique,
on appelle ça un bug.
Un son qui s’arrête, un « glitch »,
un effet qui se déclenche par hasard,
une voix qui ralentit et qui tourne
en boucle à l’infini,
et ça me rend folle !
Je me sens fragile devant cette machine
qui a une logique imparable
et en même temps, elle bugue !
Et moi, je suis à la merci
de ces accidents.
Mais si je me souviens que la pénicilline
a été inventée par accident,
les bulles de champagne, l’Amérique,
ont été découvertes par accident !
Alors je me mets à observer ces accidents,
à les accueillir au lieu d’aller contre,
pour voir où ils me mènent.
Et de ce truc-là qui ne fonctionnait pas,
(Son : Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha)
j’en ai fait ça :
(Son « ha » allongé)
(Musique en plus du « ha »)
De ce truc-là qui ne fonctionnait pas,
(Son électronique répété)
j’en ai fait ça.
(Même son, rythmé et harmonisé)
Et dans ce dialogue qui s’installe,
j’ai parfois l’impression qu’on est deux.
Je me dis : « Est-ce moi ou la machine ? »
Cette machine devient
une source d’inspiration.
Elle m’aide à créer, à penser autrement,
à sortir du cadre
de ce que je ferais toute seule.
Elle me rend meilleure,
plus forte, plus créative.
Elle devient un partenaire de jeu,
un alter ego avec qui
je joue de la musique.
Avoir un lien affectif
avec son instrument,
les musiciens font ça depuis toujours.
Matthieu Chedid a écrit
« Qui de nous deux ? » pour sa guitare.
BB King appelait sa guitare Lucile.
Et c’est la même chose pour
les instruments technologiques.
Éliane Radigues, une des pionnières
de la musique électronique,
a dit avoir vécu une histoire d’amour
avec son synthétiseur.
Et Thomas Bangalter, des Daft Punk,
considère la technologie
comme un membre du groupe à part entière.
Alors, c’est décidé,
moi aussi, je baptise mon instrument.
Elle est unique,
c’est ma sœur numérique
et je vais l’appeler UNICA.
J’ai envie d’aller plus loin dans
cette conversation avec UNICA
et pour échanger avec elle,
il faut lui trouver une voix.
La mienne.
Elle peut être l’extension
de mes cordes vocales
et à travers ma voix,
je découvre la sienne.
(Voix robotique) Et voilà
(Voix robotique distordue)
comment je rencontre ma sœur numérique,
UNICA,
une machine
avec qui je joue
de la musique.
De la musique, de la musique,
de la musique, de la musique…
(Diminuendo) de la musique, de la musique…
(Voix normale) Derrière ma voix organique
se dévoilent de nouvelles sonorités,
de nouvelles textures, un nouveau monde
vaste et infini qui s’ouvre à moi !
De nouvelles idées,
de nouvelles chansons.
Je ne suis définitivement plus seule
dans mon home studio, ni sur scène.
Nous sommes deux.
Eh oui, je passe beaucoup de temps
dans ce laboratoire,
en solitaire,
et ce n’est pas toujours facile.
Même si aujourd’hui on est deux,
il n’y a pas d’inspiration divine.
Sting dit :
« On n’invente pas une chanson,
à force de la chercher, on la trouve. »
Et c’est vrai, une mélodie
peut naître en cinq minutes.
Mais en faire une vraie chanson,
c’est beaucoup de travail de persévérance.
La créativité, c’est un travail.
Se rencontrer, c'est un travail.
Et dans ce parcours,
le hasard est un allié.
Au final, UNICA,
c’est l’enfant intérieur
qui vit en chacun de nous.
C’est cette part de rêve et d’imagination
qu’on oublie trop souvent
en devenant adulte.
Créer, imaginer,
inventer des histoires, rêver,
ce n’est pas un don que
certains artistes ont la chance d’avoir,
mais bien une qualité que nous avons tous
et qui nous définit
en tant qu’être humain.
Nous avons cette capacité à mettre de la
poésie dans le monde qui nous entoure.
Et dans un instrument,
même si c’est une machine.
Les outils, quels qu’ils soient,
si on les pousse suffisamment loin et
qu’on les pratique suffisamment longtemps,
peuvent nous permettre de nous reconnecter
avec notre enfant intérieur
et de lui donner les moyens de s'exprimer.
Cette rencontre est souvent
le fruit du hasard.
Chez moi, c’est arrivé par une boîte
en carton que je ne voulais pas ouvrir.
Et pourtant, UNICA était à l’intérieur
et aujourd’hui, je me reconnais
dans le miroir qu’elle me tend.
La musique que je fais aujourd’hui
est le résultat d’une collaboration
avec mon instrument, ma sœur numérique.
Et vous ?
Comment allez-vous par votre travail,
vos explorations, vos doutes, vos erreurs,
laisser le hasard vous rencontrer
et exprimer qui vous êtes ?
Quel est votre instrument ?
Parce que quand vous l’aurez trouvé,
dites-vous qu’il en cache
peut-être d’autres.
J’aimerais vous présenter…
le petit frère d’UNICA !
Parce qu’aujourd’hui, on est trois !
(Musique : « UNICA’s Cloud »)
Hovering Over my head
Memories Video replay
The day I rode for the first time
The songs I wrote, so many files
The sunset in your eyes
The flowers on the wall
And the day I finally woke up
Finally figured out
Unica’s Cloud
(Fin de la musique)
(Acclamations)(Applaudissements)